when did you start boxing start at 8
years old and coming in from the
football field and oh wow and I wanted
to hit the speed back but the man said
you gotta be on the boxing team I said
well I want to be on the box then he
said nope and it's for 4 days he kept
that no then on that Friday and I looked
at him he looked at me and he shook his
head and I ran up being away and he let
me in and told me I don't want you to
hit the speed back on what you hit the
heavy bag so I hit it with all my kin
and I've knocked the skin off my
knuckles and he's still laughing when he
stole a laugh and I just kept hitting
him like this and he said you're good
thank you he said do you know you could
be like Muhammad Ali as I'm only eight
years old he said you won't always be
eight and when he said that I knew next
week our gonna be I will gonna be none
so I believe so
he asked me what did I think I told Matt
I asked my mama he said what I said I
gotta ask my mama so he told me he said
go ask that good mama that you got and
see what she say I said mama she's what
I said the white man at the boys club
said I could be like Muhammad Ali and my
mama said do you know what they gonna do
to you I said well no she's they gonna
hit you when she said that I looked at
her and I started laughing I get three
weapons a day all my brothers and sister
get a chance to hit me I can t hit them
back so my mom said well well you can't
hit them back like then she told me I
can get on the boxing team I go and in
the bathroom I looked at the mirror and
see Evander Holyfield a heavyweight
champ of the world it didn't sound good
but I said I kept saying it every time I
go to the bathroom I like this cuz I
really want to make my mama proud
so I go back and tell miss Morgan my
mama said I could be the heavyweight
champion of the world and he looked at
what I said my mama say I could be the
heavyweight champ of the world
now I'm thinking this overnight Asian
sees the Sun sit down let me tell you
this I don't have that much time because
he was 60 years old Miss Morgan and he
said i hain't got that much time he said
do you know what panaceas I said and I
said no he said I said cuz I got to
knows he's come hain't got that my son
he said this is what you what a fantasy
a fantasy when you want to do something
but Jane willing to work at it he said
oh so is this a fantasy of gold
he's called I ain't got that much time I
said well a goal he's okay then you
fight tomorrow the next day they putting
on the gloves and stuff and like that he
said he see that kid right there I said
yes sir he said when the bell ring I
want you to run out that fast you can
and hit him in the nose and I said okay
so I looked at the kid and their coach
told him to run away hit me in the nose
and so my coach Harvey didn't know what
my mama had told him he need to listen
father action don't quit now
if you don't make him do that then he's
not gonna box no more I said okay the
bell ring I run out there another kid
run out there so the white kid got close
to me and he closed his eyes I didn't
close my eyes I hit him red in the nose
and he strike crying he said Oh God and
I started crying and the referee stopped
the fight mr. Morgan get caught up in
the ropes trying to get in there and he
get through and he says do you know what
you've done
I said you told me to hit him in the
nose
they said yeah you took your first step
in being a heavyweight champ of the
world like this hand Wow and they give
me this trophy so when I come home with
their and I I showed the trophy to my
mama and my mum put that smile on her
face and she put it on the shelf
everybody came in the house with said
Miss Holyfield
who is the boxer and she would look at
she was smile and said that little one
right there
they said he lived my mama said buddy he
can fight and that started off